so uh i had heard you talk about this
18-month sprints that you do
and that planning that you do around it
maybe you could explain that a little
bit for
founders and why it's important yeah i
mean everyone runs their company
differently so you know
examples of all sorts and i don't know
ours has worked well for us
we we talk about it as kind of the
strategy neapolitan where there are a
few different layers
like mission vision like you know we
think of that on like a
you know five-year horizon like three to
five year horizon
and then in and and so those don't
change very often that's our north star
but then you know we have uh
departmental okrs that are quarterly and
that's way too big a difference between
those two things so we have two other
layers in the middle
um there is a strategy that is an
18-month strategy so we kind of revisit
that
on that time frame and then there are
company okrs that are every six months
every year is too long six months seems
like the right kind of like
cadence to optimize for so there's kind
of the first half of the year companies
sprint the back half
but then every quarter each department
is is updating their okrs
um and so that that what's nice about
that especially as the ceo
is i'd like to not be critical path for
everything
you know we really want to push down in
the organization decision making
which has a lot of benefits right people
feel empowered they feel appreciated
they have a bigger impact and i don't
really like to micromanage
so if you can kind of get everyone on
the same page about where we're going in
18 months
people can start to be smart about how
they slot things in now versus later and
kind of have those open
cross-departmental conversations about
what are the trade-offs and what's the
right ordering of stuff
so you know and then based on that
18-month roadmap
yeah we look at well what's the team we
need to to get that done
and then from that we kind of back out
okay well you know like
on what time are we going to hire them
how much is that going to cost and then
do we need to raise more money
and you know the last time we raised
money was in 2018 we raised
five million from dcm and we actually
had a term sheet for 20
but we just saw i'd i'm with
dcm and kyle louise on our board there
from there and um you know he's really
on board with how we run the business
and so you know as you mentioned we're
now profitable very casual positive
and i always tell our team that that's
not the goal but we also don't keep
score based on head count or dollars
raised we keep score based on
growth like are we building a big
company or not
and my co-founders are also engineers
and so the three of us
have worked at hyper growth companies
before and especially when you're trying
to scale up
engineering if you scale it too quickly
it ends up being confusing people don't
know exactly what they're working on you
spend most your time interviewing
and it can actually be detrimental to
your ability to make progress
you know on you know 12 18 month horizon
so
we'll grow our engineering team 50 in
the next year um
we grow other departments based on need
as you mentioned earlier 100 of our
deal flow is inbound it's 90 95
self-serve
um and engineering and product and
design is our is our biggest spend as a
company and that's where we think we
have the longest term
differentiation and
you try to do sas sales
and have a big sales team but the
problem with your sales team was
if your average sale was 20 grand
uh or it cost you whatever 20 grand to
make a sale when you take the entire
sales team together and you divide their
whole book of business
you know it might cost twenty thousand
dollars for an at scale
enterprise sas company uh in your case
to make a sale
but that was your average uh yearly
spend so you're basically in the hole
and you only make money if they're
renewed for the second year so you
disbanded the whole thing correct
as a failed experiment it wasn't a
failed experiment
i think it would have been much more
capital intensive to do that
and i when i when i see or talk to
founders who are kind of starting out
sometimes they'll be like oh we're going
to have self-serve and enterprise sales
and i'm always like no no
you got to pick one go to market motion
and stick with it like superhuman being
a great example
i'm sure that superhuman could spin up
an outbound sales team the question is
is that the best use of their time
right now and the answer is probably not
um and so you do see a lot of examples
of product live growth companies that
then later on put on top in enterprise
sales motion
which is probably what we would do as
well it just happens to be the case that
we can get more growth
out of the strategies that we're
currently pursuing so we did spend two
years selling up markets specifically in
sales enablement
and that was working fine it was more
capital intensive and the math as you
point out means you just need
more upfront cost there's a lot of risk
in terms of you know your sdr's maybe
not working or
you know scaling your ae team and you
really need to have big big acvs
for that to be worthwhile an average
customer
average contract value contract value
right
so if you're you know paying your cost
of
acquiring your deal is twenty thousand
dollars and you're only making twenty
thousand dollars in the first year that
math is not going to work out it needs
to be like 100k
or above and opinions on this vary but
you want to be really targeting
um those companies and dachshund has a
lot of public companies we have a lot of
big contracts
but for a 55-person team i think it's
better to just focus us on building for
the end user
which is not necessarily smb versus
enterprise it's just that we we build
for the person using our software
versus the economic buyer at a big
company
you know and and those are just two
different feature sets and
it both both strategies can work i just
think for small companies you
probably should pick one because then
you are setting yourself up to be better
at it
everybody knows that zendesk is the
go-to tool for
customer support it's the gold standard
but what you may not know
is zendesk also offers a suite of sales
tools
designed to remove the difficulties of
sales software so sales teams like yours
can go spend more time on what really
matters to their business
which of course is having better
customer conversations even better
zendesk is offering this suite of sales
tools
plus their industry leading support
software for free
for six months as part of the zendesk
for startups program think about that
along with the free access to all of
zendesk as part of the program you'll
also get access to
zendesk's community of startup founders
and partners who will teach you
all the best practices to better serve
your customers and they'll even offer
dedicated onboarding guidance and
support to get you
up and running in no time steezy one of
our great investments here at launch
they teach people how to dance it's a
subscription service think calm
meditation it's easy for dance they rely
on zendesk and they love it they use the
combination of zendex explorer
and their ticket tagging system so that
they can track
which features their users want and that
they're most excited about
and then they take all of that
information from the customer support
channel
and they give it to the product team
right get six months of zendesk for free
at zendesk.com
twist and to qualify for this program
because they're giving it to you for
free
they just ask that you have under 50
employees and you've raised a series a
or below right so if you're a series b
and you got 100 employees why don't you
go ahead and pay for the product okay
but this is zendesk
for startups it's free zendesk.com twist